my name is Paul de Kamali I'm general
manager of three meals studio is a
lovely little island of creativity in
East London but I'm here to help
facilitate the most fantastic session
that you would have seen today the
nominees BAFTA nomination to be the
Oscar nominees also for 2008 for best
production design I've lost track of how
many nominations awards etc the panel
has been has won or been nominated for
so I'm not going to go into them what I
am going to do is ask each panelist to
introduce themselves the film or films
that they are nominated for then we're
going to watch those relevant clips
maybe get a few words from each one
after each clip and then we'll jump into
the session we certainly want to leave
time for questions at the end I'm going
to keep my questions to the minimum
hopefully just keep things rolling along
with this fantastic panel so let's start
with these self introductions okay I'm
in wood production designer of beating
the beast and darkest hour
I'm Katie Spencer set the crater Beauty
and the Beast darkest hour we're gonna
jump right now to those is my
understanding before we do so everyone
links it in
[Music]
[Music]
you must leave here discuss is alive
who's there
do you wish to take your father's place
commence the light
show me the girl look at her what if she
is the one dawn will break the spell
hello you can talk well of course he
couldn't tell hello
pleased to meet you the Masters not as
terrible as he appears
[Music]
me
think the one things you've always
wanted
find it your mind's eye and field
[Music]
don't be afraid
I'm afraid
[Music]
let them see your true qualities my poor
judgment your sense of humor ho ho
Your Majesty mr. Churchill I invite you
to take up the position of Prime
Minister
he's an actor in love with the sound of
his own voice the Lord privy seal
[Music]
champagne lunch dinner he is not
powering it up we are looking for the
collapse of Western Europe in the next
few days you are squatters already
victory you're suggesting where somehow
winning we're not if it true we're in
full retreat all our forces are known
dunker
well we cannot reach them they're
pushing us into the sea
there is the question of peace talks on
between ourselves in Germany still
Europe is lost
no charge
you have the full weight of the world on
your shoulders
how many men was fire
then to the people tell them the truth
these trousers to liberate resistance
the nothing patriotic in fighting to the
end now is the time to negotiate when
they learn you cannot reason with a
tiger when your head is in its mouth I
take full responsibility really really
yes it is the reason I sit in this chair
[Music]
himself
so fights all the regions we shall fight
on the landing grounds we shall fight in
the fields
in the streets
we shall fight in the Hills we shall
never
for Williams victory there can be no
summer
[Applause]
production designer Blade Runner
let's go
you
you
[Music]
[Applause]
Nathan Crowley
[Music]
[Music]
break
you saw me
I'm on em
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Paul Auster berry shape of water and
Jeff Melvin's out there set decorator if
I told you a motor
the princess without voice what would I
say
[Music]
she deaf mute she can hear you you clean
that lab you get out this may very well
be the most sensitive asset ever to be
housed in this facility
you may think that thing looks human
stands on two legs right but we're
created in the Lord Jim you don't think
that's what the Lord looks like yeah
this creature is intelligent capable of
language of understanding emotions
[Music]
when he looks at me he doesn't know how
I am incomplete he sees me as I the
natives in the Amazon wears it doesn't
get him out you need to take it apart
learn how it works
[Music]
I don't want an intricate beautiful
thing destroyed we could do nothing
I'm sorry don't do this alasa what is
she sorry
don't do this it's not even human
if I told you about her what would I say
I wonder
[Music]
[Applause]
so I tied race obviously BAFTAs Oscars
good luck to you all
I'd like to start off just talking about
Dunkirk and darkest hour in particular
around the topic of research in the
process of production design inspiration
in particular about recreating
historical locations some went to the
historical location others interpreted
the historical location
Nathan you want to start with yeah I
mean we you know this is very different
design job I usually do a Christopher
Nolan it was you know trying to find
somewhere to start was was difficult
beyond the research so we early always
just said let's go to Dunkirk so we went
to Dunkirk a little bit incognito for
him no one knows who I am
there he just wore a t-shirt and shorts
like a summer vacation but we went there
and warped our research was walking 18
mile we won't be in tar Beach because
and realized that event took place over
this vast space from Belgium 26 KS in
and so we walked 18 miles and talked it
through and we saw as the tide went in
and out during that in tar day we we
sort of arrived back at the east mole
which is where most of the troops got
off that didn't exist anymore
and realized we didn't really have any
choice in we were making this sort of we
were gonna make as practically we we
just had to shoot in Dunkirk that was
the film we were gonna make
there was no faking it so which was
which is again one of those moments I
always have one a film which was just
like oh my god we have to to try and do
this event and have to do it for real so
it's always sort of the optimism you
need to start a film it is it's very
important we're gonna come back to you
in terms of
later but Sarah you had a different
approach with with attack Estella yeah I
mean it's duck stock interestingly we
knew that Nathan and Odin we're making
Dunkirk and there was a lot of you know
conversations and it was kind of like
well whatever they're doing they're
doing in their way and we will not be
doing that because apart from anything
else our budget was like but also this
the the the script you know it was it
was it was a very kind of internal it
was a very kind of cerebral and it was
just it was it was something much more
about kind of it was kind of the
underbelly of what was going on and you
know what was interesting was the script
you know the script started off as
something it was a bit grey men in grey
rooms it was a lot of chat and you know
didn't seem to go out anywhere but
obviously knowing Joe and the way Joe
works you know that we can be you know
we could bring some life to it with ways
of interpreting it and and also unlike
that I mean interestingly talking about
the covers of the realism and you know
the these are real kind of real people
know characters they're real people you
know Churchill our center you know he
was real as real as it goes I mean you
look at Gary's performance you look at
that amazing prosthetics you look at his
costumes his kind of artifacts and all
of that and so at the heart of it you
have this incredibly real thing but
around it it's the essence of it it's
the it's the feeling of that we wanted
to create about the wall we were not
looking at verbatim recreation because
you know we couldn't afford it it
wouldn't have been necessary the right
thing we were looking for the atmosphere
of kind of kind of desperation and
coming out of the depression and also I
for me I like the idea of this
counterpoint to two films that the
downfall and Valkyrie and they are
fantastic films that kind of showing how
the Nazis were approaching things you
know that there was this massive war
machine that was just rolling
through Europe and you know what we were
were this kind of completely unprepared
you know the way we were doing it was so
kind of wrong you know and and so there
we were you know we ended up in this
bunker with string and pins and that was
literally how they won the war and you
know to try and kind of convey that was
was very ad hoc wasn't it yeah the whole
of the macaron down there and the bun
was very our talk if they were ran out
of chairs it was who's got a spare chair
at home can somebody bring something in
yeah and this is the last country
fighting the Nazis yeah and you know it
was it and it was you know so they
thought I will be safe underneath you
know Whitehall and then they realized oh
maybe not if a bomb lands on the war
office above it'll just collapse on top
of them so they bought in these naval
architects who's stuck in these wooden
pillars you know because that's all they
could do and it was just like you know
how kind of weirdly planned I did read
something we say we're not a documentary
and in counterpoint to Dunkirk as as
well you know you're the politics and
the intimate detail to their action and
scale yeah how do you how do you see
that no I mean we we I mean Chris he
always invites me to lunch and it's like
usually it's 186 pages long and I'm a
slow reader
this one was 46 pages like like what do
you say we're gonna do something
different we're gonna make an event
we're gonna we need to put people in
this place because there's plenty of
great war films has been made and we
have to do our version of it and we have
to explain
there are things were seal and so yeah I
mean once we sort of got a flavor of
Dunkirk we were going to dunk her we use
a real spear for us we use real
destroyers so we you know the research
was was already there so I themed were
the sort of Brutalism of that place and
how you you know you were in this sort
of Groundhog Day thing you couldn't get
off you got if you managed to get onto a
ship it was sunk or torpedoed it was
night there was no way out and you know
and it was a
about desperation and and you know and
how how these people survived to fight
another day and the French you know you
thought the France had fallen they were
supposedly especially going on the boat
to it was this sort of great disaster
and the reason I think I like most most
proud of as we landed that Spitfire and
on cove beach with Dunkirk markings and
it was just we had trouble getting it
off but you get the speed fires because
I was reading you found some speed fires
that were marked fives or whatever but
you know at the beginning of the war
they were marked ones or something so in
terms of accuracy and detail what did
you do when you talked you just talking
about Dunkirk marking I was you know I
sort of as we were sort of finding the
film the reason it was a slightly
different film because it was hard to
find design themes you know I went at
Duxford and I've looked at the Spitfire
they pulled out the sand of Dunkirk and
it was like that's our Spitfire and you
know you know people are like they
refused to come so we had some great
text at Lyon to mark ones in a mark 5 so
he he flew he flew mostly Smith thousand
mark ones but from one of them which we
changed from our fight to mark one but
the hardest thing you know was there was
a I mean we used a two-seater yak which
a Russian warplane we put cameras on the
wings but we had to rebuild a Spitfire
cockpit in the front seat so the flyer
the pilot can be in the second C so a
lot of the flight stuff was is IMAX
strapped a cat you know over dunker with
Spitfires flying on side so you know
trying to get experimental planes
through and ships to be towed and you
know so this this our research was
finding the real elements shifting into
scale in the real Adam elements you
rebuilt them all a mile of way to
rebuild a kilometer we I of course
decided I wanted to rebuild
kilometer like Chris look something like
we are mad so I mean it was amazing it
was this it was the first key image was
is a kilometer long seven foot six white
pier that goes to nowhere and it was
just pure white and the reason of his
white so a fisherman can see it and I
thought that was a great image and
literally soldiers just stacked up
waiting to be rescued than me on in fact
no single German shell actually hit them
all dead on it's too narrow so it was
the rebuild that was this film was
really the most logistical film it was
very difficult with the weather and
21-foot tide so i just--i logistically
coming up with a plan to stack a 21 foot
mole so we ended up doing 700 feet which
was which was plenty and we didn't
actually we had some decent money we
didn't have much money considering what
we were trying to do so yeah so but
really for me visually I didn't I sort
of discovered the industrial side of
Dunkirk which I became very interested
in for we had our things with air seal
and so the land was I wanted to really
that industrial beach I was very keen to
get out of the seafront and this sort of
traditional French the lingerie cafe
thing and get us into the industry is I
felt that represented the moral
hard-edged dare I say so modern this
machine look that I felt was important
that they kept on coming back to this
there was no niceties that kept on
coming back to this horrible place after
every attempt and get off it it was hard
to get off that Beach we weren't even
being shot that staying with the theme
of scale then Dennis and blade row 20 49
where I understand you built 90 percent
of the sets physically and big big sets
in big big places yeah
and so what what led to that decision
well the we only had one reference to
try and do in amage Orwell a
continuation really of the film that was
made you know 35 years ago and and why
it took so long you know that's another
story but the the I said we have a I
said we have one advantage we did have
more money that really had at that time
but also he was he broke the ice with
really one one big set at Warner
Brothers which I was lucky enough to see
and and I'd met really at that time at
that time because I was a beginning and
designer and and I saw the complications
that they had
so I said to Denny the owner of our
director I said well we have to stand
alone but continued you know the journey
and I think scale is going to be a real
important thing for us metaphorically
the the nature of Los Angeles the way
really created and then then growing on
top of that thirty-five years later with
with the brutality that we intended gave
us and also the weather the compact
compounded with a there brutalist of the
weather was we needed to have a bigger
scale it's like the pyramids we needed
to build the pyramids
to withstand the elements and so that
was the real reason for the scale I
think and we and it was a stage based
movie we went to Budapest Hungary to
make it Ridley had done the Martian
there and he suggested at London had no
stay
for us so we I was a little hesitant
about it until I went there I kind of
fell in love with Budapest it was really
I thought there's some off something to
offer here like sure yet what but in the
course of designing the film we we
discovered there were some elements that
we couldn't build on stage and and we
folded those in to to the scale issues
and so on so was it but guys have
mentioned the Brutalism and brutality
can you fill us in a bit about you know
in talking to your directors you know
the words that you used together to try
and come up with the initial ideas and
all please jump in there but I are where
does love a normally so yeah love and
harmony in cop in contrast to that yeah
well brutality was I asked any I said
what if you could describe the movie in
one word and I do this often with
directors say well we need to find
something to hold on to and so
synthesize it they kind of create a rule
out of the idea and he came back very
quickly I said brutality and I said
fantastic it it so how do you create
something that's quite brutal but then
also the to contrast it so that it's
just not so so it has to be somewhat
forgiving as well too in the sense
because you've got kind of a romance
going on we've got all these these
different images and different emotions
that are being played you know a you
know potential potential you know son
son to a father and all of these these
issues that the underlines
actor of the film which is very much the
way literally was kind of playing it and
what the way didn't he thought we could
we could arrive at something that was
interesting and and so that food
brutality was the word but how do you
make something little brutal beautiful
yeah and that's that's what the Deacons
in the lighting would come back to the
t'lani and stuff later and Sarah okay do
you want to throw in some some words for
either or both of your films when
working on Beauty and the Beast and in
darkest hour I mean you know you're
always looking for the keys in the ways
in and I think for booting the beast the
weird one which will send shivers down
the spine of some of our colleagues who
are here is a Rococo which is um it's
kind of a kind of mad kind of design
kind of element from 1740s France so
it's not so yeah so so that became quite
brutal actually as we're drawing it and
having to deal with it
listening to what we were doing and and
darkest era well I think they I suppose
the both I mean especially both in the
way about survival and getting through
it and resignation and all of that but
dogstars challenges were different very
different because economically it was
challenged and we were all over the
country and a very tight schedule Joe's
quite a sort of you know demanding
director as well as brilliant to work
with work for but pedantic is well I
didn't
[Laughter]
well excuse me I mean mixed up a flu fog
here I'll get other people talking Paul
I want you to lead please on it on a
question we've always been you know
we've all been talking about Outsiders
color palette and maybe that could be
something that you and Jeff might like
to delve into a bit more deeply in terms
of the shape of the water and shape of
water and how you dealt with that and
working with Guillermo and on that I can
comment a bit about Brutalism week it
does work for our film as well because
we have this romantic side that sort of
late Victorian old decrepit architecture
of her apartments about this old movie
theater and we wanted to contrast that
with Brutalism and I use their
architectural style of international
Brutalism it was very prevalent in the
50 60 70 s and for institutions and so
there was a we wanted the very harsh
differences between the two to two
settings her home her work life and we
chose a brutalist building in Toronto
and then we based that the style of that
architecture we took in interior to all
the studio sets we were mmm I would say
like 75% studio of 25% location for a
very small movie we did vary quite a lot
of building I'm so Brutalism does work
in context of our movie about love and
acceptance and everything as well but
color palette is very very strong in the
film and Guillermo I've only worked
close gamal finished one film with
Guillermo I've been working on three
films with him over the past three years
but only one has been seeing it through
and that I think was a good one
thankfully but but he the first thing
the first day I came into the office I
mean we had been talking about this film
for a year because I had the script a
rough draft or a year prior to that in
2015 but we we came to the office with I
had 10 weeks but my rhetoric came in
with 8 weeks of prep and when we
actually had the office the first day
was pull out the big Benjamin Moore
catalog you know he has an idea in his
mind about where the colour was gonna be
anyway so we just quickly spent 45
minutes just tagging going through all
little colour swatches tagging them all
and just a sign of different characters
and then Louis the costume designer did
exactly we did exactly the same thing
with his fabric swatches and then we had
they're not well that was maybe a
hundred colors and so then I narrowed it
down to about forty collars and stuck
him on a board and the Louis did the
same with his and then we made each
other boards and so we had them in our
office and my background as an architect
color is not generally the the strong
point of architectural training so I
always have I always ought to be the
first to admit I struggle with I agonize
over the color takes me a lot longer
than the three-dimensional space but
because because gammaroid kind of had an
idea in his head and not all directors
do about color I mean this is very very
lucky so he oh he already kind of
narrowed the world down so then for me
was very easy then to pick the colors
because I had we'd already narrowed it
down and then I could just refine it and
then again was Jeff for furnishings and
things we knew we're well with
furnishings we could actually obviously
recover things and stuff like that but
essentially everything was color blocked
you know we knew what colors were gonna
be for each particular character and
essentially in the broad strokes you
know the aqua tones and the underwater
colors were basically Eliza's apartment
I'm in her world he contrasts that with
the opposite side which is John's
apartment which is very earthy mustards
Gold's warm warm color and it was also
in conversation with Dan Laos and the DP
he lit he lit Eliza's apartment with
steel blue gels and kept in a cool
palette and then on the other hand the
young contrasting other side of the
hallway was always like golden hour even
though there was a golden hour it seemed
to last all day long but anyway he lit
it by golden hour all the time and all
the other empathetic characters in the
story Zelda and Hostetler who was
Russian spy who you wouldn't think his
empathetic his world we created in that
same warm palette just so that you know
that was that team empathy know had that
color and then and then getting back to
the Brutalism
when we went into Strickland's lab where
he was based out of you know I kind of
wanted that to be on purpose we chose
our Brutalism because it was harsh harsh
concrete's materials and then his I put
his office elevated because he looked
down on everyone he always felt
everyone's beneath
walk down to them and was really abusive
so we put him kind of above everybody
and he had this outside his world
there was this mural of we did this tile
mural that was in the same teal colors
that were healed was the color the
feature by the way it's in the script
when he's buying a car that salesman
pitches teal is the color of future so
he mo has color written into his script
in this case and so we basically
everything was basically monochromatic
concrete but we had this teal teal theme
throughout that whole lab complex so
that was kind of a basic color design
that we had for the for the film the
pretty simplistic but it was you know
I'm color coded and after has tried to
replicate this yes I know I'm in the
wrong seats will fold it teal and
serese-- while you yeah chanting Paul
there's been some slides going on here
and maybe you could art director he was
being he wasn't very good asset but he
was trying to yeah
posing as the creature you know
basically we did a lot of stuff in I
draw a lot of things in Sketchup and
then my team does a big team you know
it's not just us who are sitting up here
is a huge team or this case not that big
a team on this movie but and then this
is some of the progress of the
particular set if we can just hold that
there because you again I you do the
asset is a God in South America and I
was reading you know the the pool is
designed on a pyramid shape and even the
the pipes are like a Setting Sun or you
know those sorts of things you permeate
the whole the whole yeah those little
details and their demo has a sketchbook
and he had he had a sketchbook when he
when he was imagining the creature being
found in the Amazon that he emerges out
of the water and there was a sunset
behind him you know like a Setting Sun
he's like this godlike creature in the
Amazon so when we were the first time we
see the creature emerged not in a tank
but emerge out of the water is in as in
this pool is above-ground pool and so I
said it I kind of thought I'll take the
archetypal ziggurat form of a stepped
pyramid a lot of civilizations did that
and it's a very stylized little simple
simple one you'd pop out of there and
then Guillermo said let's and we were
gonna do some pipes back there he said
well maybe let's try to keep some house
do a version of that Setting Sun that he
had in his mind from from his little
sketch book so we did sort of this
steampunk version
of this pipes and going back to research
by the way in you know at the very very
beginning to even though it's a
fantastical Guillermo del Toro sort of
movie we we started with serious
research because we really wanted to set
the period as early 60s that was
important and then you know after you
look at this obviously we've pushed it a
lot but but we wanted to ground
ourselves in that period so that that
that was done and then we can push it
from there so research is important in
any kind of movie I think bullets and
jump back there in terms of color
palette might jump back to you Sarah and
Kyle Young on Beauty and the Beast which
where I saw it
especially you love bring brought up on
musicals my mother's desire for musicals
and I sort of saw it as yeah Carla
pushed up to 11 you know but fantastic
the flower scene and all that sort of
stuff do you want to talk a bit more
about coloring in beauty in the base yes
and that's working closely with
Jacqueline Christian design a small
quiet village it was quite busy yeah
yeah that was that's in the song as well
you have to follow what what they're
singing a builds idea of a small village
he really just didn't catch it because
he's a New Yorker born and bred and just
like anyway so yeah that was an intranet
was the interesting set anyway because
we were originally going to go and shoot
that on location and I quite like the
idea of shooting on location as a
contrast to the fact that when we go
into the enchanted world everything is
you know it was built is built and you
know the real world had had had a
reality to it but obviously studios come
at you with budget and logistics and say
okay Sarah it will cost we so we found
some fantastic locations in France and
it came back with a lot of information
and they said right this is how much
it'll cost to take the whole kit and
kaboodle to France if we gave you this
can you build it and then by then and we
were well into production it was like it
was like starting a new film on the
backlog with the new construction team
and everything and
what's not to like build a French
village an 18th century French religion
is like wow this is amazing opportunity
so you know and then and then you know
it just kind of it all just kind of
happened
but interesting interesting color it's
it's kind of like it's it's the cut the
color the color there isn't one
particular color I don't think with
Beauty the Beast it's more it's the
style actually it says it's going back
to you know finding how you can do the
enchantment and it's finding that key
and that was literally Rococo and I'm
not being facetious this time you know
so Rococo this style of exuberant kind
of fanciful design very asymmetric and
what I found was two etchings one which
was a pretty pure piece of Rococo and
another one which was like Rococo gone
mad it was like somebody had like done
something to it and they were both of
kind of mirrors and fireplaces and it
was just excessive and that's what
struck me because you know in the
enchantment it's this feeling that it
carried on moving and carried on growing
and that every time a petal fell some
parts of the castle just twisted a bit
more and so it was it was like we didn't
want it to be damp and derelict and
green and overgrown it was just kind of
heaving and kind of moving I mean it was
incredible the Rococo because it
transferred even to the you know the set
of the enchanted woods and everything
everything was carved in okay okay the
decoration on the on the bell jar was
carved for real and they were a cocoa
patent the frost on the windows so that
was really ran through everything that
was I had been charmed in it and then in
darkest hour you still the pepper okay
but it seems to me you even though it's
in color are having Watchers like oh
it's almost in black and white except
you're the grain of the of the
Parliament and other things particularly
in the war rooms but it was you know was
that something that you were trying to
push through there was a photographer
that we liked in particular kind of
1950s late 50s photographer late 50s but
and the quality of that was the quality
that we were looking at was Jacqueline
and Bruno and what we were doing and
obviously it can be done in the grain
and it could be done in you know in post
and things but it was like
to capture that and also the classic
photo the classic was as classic I think
it I don't whether it's a beaten or not
but this M ed ed wiener my apartment you
know all her glory leaving against a
fireplace in some grand house in London
but everything is shabby she has the
Paulo the smoker her makeup is a bit
smeared that you know the fires going
out and the paint's chips and unless one
half is disgusting yeah you know so that
so that even even you know at that time
even for the aristocracy it was hard and
that was one of the things that we
wanted to get across education so he was
talked about you know in Buckingham
Palace is the fact that you know
everything that we did there so this
empty old house we shot in in Yorkshire
was very tawdry haven't been painted for
50 60 years
but you know everything that Katy
brought in with the furnishings so you
know that the instead of going for gold
you know you went for kind of five
points down you know so everything that
we did was just right sat down and you
know we stuck up this huge kind of
envision bomb blast shutters up the
window so you know Porto Bruno's
lighting opportunity is amazing you know
so which of course you know so the
palace isn't a palace that such as a
quite a quality of tonal food there we
go it's all about the mood and Dennis in
Blade Runner then a strong color palette
again lack of color in some way you know
the I designed the film originally used
all in black and white and then slowly
we started that color into it to trying
to find the rhythm of the sequencing of
each of the story and the producer said
where's the color was the color was
crisis is coming it's coming it's coming
it's coming cos it was like they were so
nervous about the lack of it because
it's it was a dark environment a lot of
ways and of course the the when the
choice of for Vegas was was this
wonderful kind of muted orange that we'd
seen a researcher picture of Sydney
Australia that
this amazing storm coming off that off
the off the desert and all of Sydney was
this color it was so magical and it just
in then it justified the kind of the
smart bomb that was initially put there
to kind of take everybody away from
Vegas and then Harris justifying
Harrison's existence at that point and
then I mean the yeah it was a was dark
felt the dark film that that and I think
it should have been you know the
bringing the color in the babies bar was
or Orion that meets meets a couple of
the girls that carry the story on was
was probably the the most unique in the
color palette of this wall to but that
was a bit of a marsh back to the
original film because that was the
original set that really had done with
all the neon and and that was a that's
where the life of that that his home
came but we knew the contrast that with
the fatality so and and I can the the
darkness the bleakness the
relentlessness of junker I'm interested
in contrast so that that's always key
for me as I push contrasts so
cinematography it helps the
cinematographers I I I often like the
white Pierre was an obvious contrast to
the see we had this weird we had such
big word that come out as that weird
foam was hitters for a week it looks
like you know Doctor Zhivago
out there so we immediately ran to what
I used to call the Industrial Beach and
the Industrial Beach was this slightly
not period beach but it had all this
sort of steaming industry like we'd been
looking at films like red desert and
wages of fear and battle end years yeah
so you know we wanted that sort of
mechanical nurse
would enhance the ticking clocks we
pulled these ticking clocks everywhere
so wasn't really about Cairo's us about
contrasts so we had to find one of the
hardest things was that upside-down hull
which is in the sea about five miles out
on the inland sea it was very hard to
find enough contrast with that hull but
luckily the the moon the boat the white
boat comes to see you start you fill the
sky to see and these two elements it was
always about contrast
I didn't bring my watch as a great
moderator Dennis can you tell me the
time I can't or you said are you set on
Toronto John time's up time's up 4:30
well we're gonna sleep goin for a little
while can't wait Cassandra four
questions or not fine five minutes I'm
sorry I took so much time when but look
can we let me not take any more time is
anyone got any questions don't forget we
have Jeff here to set set designer for
shape of water if you'd like to ask any
queries anyone we've got one here and
then one at the very back and then one
day if you can remind me I were going up
the back first hi um I wanted to ask
Katie and Sarah about the significance
of shooting in Westminster and whether
that was a challenge or and how much you
were able to do there yeah we shot it
real Downing Street and intermedia into
the Treasury and quite frankly that's
just pure nepotism because Eric Felner
it was a very good friend of David
Cameron's and got us in there before he
got Cameron got kicked out and luckily
to resume honoured the commitment
allowing her to film outside an industry
that was that that was that we we
building we built the interiors
elsewhere but the the exterior I mean it
was great and they showed us around
which was fantastic and then we shot in
West
all and we were offered like I said we
were offered the House of Commons but we
couldn't sit down so that's as much as
we used do you rebuild that and in
Downing Street you're in Downing Street
interiors and not like Downing Street no
damn Street interior nothing like the
real down the street because Joe Joe
likes to Joe likes to move a lot and he
like 360 environments and it's quite
kind of ad hoc sometimes and and also
one of the interesting things that we
found out about Churchill was that he
moved at a pace and he moves really fast
which was interesting and so you know
there was a certain pace to it and so we
found this derelict house in again in
Yorkshire that they allowed us to do
what we wanted to so so it has it has
all the kind of feeling of Downing
Street but is nothing like them yes
right there's someone down here with a
microphone was there or someone in the
middle zone are we doing another one up
the top is that working great thank you
so much that was really interesting
I was wondering this is sort of all of
you when you first get a script what's
the first thing you're looking for story
a good story that you can hold on to and
in the who talked earlier about it's
hard to get into a film the and
something has to do to create that fire
in you you know the and that's that's
really what I'm looking for I'm looking
for something it's gonna sustain the
passion throughout you know the creative
process in the shooting process so so
it's a simply that and then then of
course you know who's doing the work you
know who's your partner I mean in
particular you know the the director and
the DP you know that that is kind of the
the foundation for me in the film in
that way you know how we're gonna are we
going to achieve all this madness okay
we're gonna do with the original people
who put their - or there's one here and
and one in the middle day if we can
quickly go there and then I'm sorry
we're gonna wrap
in terms of the lavish indoor sets and
something like Beauty and the Beast
versus the large scale and scope of the
outdoor sets such as something in
Dunkirk what are the differences in your
approach to each and in the challenges
that you face we teach those I mean
interestingly the whole thing about
buting the beast was because this was a
live-action telling of the tale the
thing that struck me was that it had to
be it had to be real because the beast
wasn't real he was CG the characters
were real as in we made them and
designed them but then they were
animated and therefore if you'd built if
you if this if the scenery around it had
been all kind of blue screen and things
then what would have been real about the
the whole process so so as far as that's
why we built the sets that we built and
that the nature of the beast of is that
it's um it's an enormous castle and you
know and and therefore scale it was
about you have the thing this event had
four hundred thousand men stuck on the
beach and another hundred thousand
French people fine troops behind us so
it's about recreating that and so scale
was sort of everything we had the IMAX
camera Chris always shoots on IMAX and
he he uses the native negative so that
means that if we scan it to do digital
work on that negative the output is a
less quality so we know we have to do
some digital work so what we have to do
as much we have to affect the film as
little as possible and project it you
know you need to start with you could
interject digital work along one scene
but you have to enter an exit with
reality so so really the biggest you
know as we talked about the biggest
challenges was maintaining the IMAX the
quality of the IMAX Nexo which is very
important to him so and he decided he I
just remember him like he have his
three-piece suit on there just jump in
the sea
get this done and became this sort of
beast and then one more here
congratulation to your wonderful work
and donations
I'm just wondering whether you have any
different approaches and consideration
when you're working on a film which is
both is going to be on 2d and 3d and
IMAX as you mentioned some problems and
how you're going to overcome it I've
worked on a few 3d movies and
essentially you know you cannot shoot
quite as wide as you well it used to be
you couldn't shoot quite as wide as you
can now if you shoot by the way there's
a lot of movies are shot in 3d and then
movies that are just created in post in
3d the one side would were in real 3d so
definitely there was a the camera setup
was a lot bigger so you have to allow
for things like that if you have a crane
moving through something the the height
I always had to figure out was you know
quite a lot bigger than a regular rig
and you have to allow for a lot of you
can't have things too close to the
camera because it messes up with you
your mind but there's certain things you
learn by just doing it that you have to
you have to adjust for I don't know
about a few ton three even to be some
real 3d even lives I don't think about
it I don't I don't actually like 3d
movies but but I have had to work on a
couple of them I think so much same for
me it's always done usually imposed
we're gonna have to wrap it there but
I'm gonna ask them together take the
Chairman's privilege to say one more
quick question to each of you for
because we know we have a lot of younger
production designers in the audience's
your biggest challenge number one skill
needed I think just a good work ethic
and energy you know I mean you can I
think as a as you're starting out as a
designer on smaller presumably you're on
smaller things is you've got to do a lot
you've got to be really hands-on and and
also just just work I mean people just
wait and wait and wait but I think
sometimes you have to jump in even if
you're not designing you just jump in
and do other things and you might find
you learn a lot from doing other
other disciplines within the film yeah
and don't you can't have a fear of if
you have to paint a backing yourself and
you've never done it then by the way
you're gonna have to do it so oh you're
gonna learn how to do it you have to you
have to be a jack-of-all-trades you've
got to keep learning the whole time in
this business years ago a million and a
half dollars and I was the mechanic on
set I had I was the special effects guy
doing the fireplace you know a lot of
these things you did I can do that in a
union film and I like doing those things
but I'm not allowed to so it was kind of
fun yeah and you remember every film is
new so it's always the first time you've
done it so there's nothing you know the
amount of experience you have it's still
where as green as you guys you know I've
never ever done Rococo before I
certainly haven't it's about learning as
a joy of learning and learning like the
place and the period and you know I find
that just keep open minded it's fine
again I'll say it again just find a good
story that you can be passionate about
and whatever it's going to take you'll
do it you'll eventually find a way of
doing it and I've done extremely small
films and big films and and it really
doesn't matter as long as the story is
there that it drives you and keeps you
keeps you going
it's a 24/7 business you know you once
you're in it you're in it yeah I think
that's true and I think is you know be
prepared to so learn all the time enjoy
it and talk to other departments all the
time I think that's a key thing keep
talking I think you know yeah you have
to love what you do they're for you
the people that surround you are
absolutely critical and your team I mean
Katie and I are lucky enough we've
worked together for 20 years and we have
an amazing team core team and people
that come and go and you know you have
to enjoy what you're doing because if
you don't it's too hard a job to do
without you know kind of pleasure in
yeah question I think what you need to
do is someone once said to me this is
how we do it and this is how we should
approach up there is no how we do it
every film is different every projects
different every story's different so
there are no rules
I think somebody said that I'd agree
100% if you put your best work out on
each project every show whether it's a
good show a bad show just do your best
work all the time you might end up there
I'll keep going maybe I'll get from here
to there fantastic thank you everyone of
course
so what only remains for me to say good
luck thank you
[Applause]
you